it's a daunting prospect to play such a
beloved character from fiction that
people have such strong affinity for
James Tigers on the fillory a villian
he's just misunderstood in your wedding
like I'm the woman in this family now
the best exchange I'm the woman in the
family and she says that's quite alright
I'm the man it's Kennedy for recent TV
and the Hollywood premiere of vine
Rand's Atlas Shrugged - we're gonna talk
with some of the actors to see how
important her messages today how did the
theme strike you did they resonate with
you how important was that to the role
ultimately I'm playing a character you
know and I needed to find a way to make
her a living breathing human being and
so you can't really play a philosophy
have to play a a perspective I don't
think it's a message film the message is
absolutely there and for those who are
looking for those points to be made it's
made but it's a really good film it's a
great story to be had and but I think
it's gonna find a broader audience
because of that and get faithful are
gonna come no matter what and hopefully
be very pleased but my hopes are it's
gonna it's gonna leak into a more
mainstream conversation because it's
conversation needs to be had were you
changed by Iran's words for me there's
no doubt that she is an incredibly
intelligent woman yeah whose perspective
is whose philosophy is based on her own
life experiences and what she witnessed
as you know sort of the failure of
communism
you know the fundamentals of freedom I
think everybody can agree with that's
that's it's just how its implemented
that people disagree and I think this is
a wonderful philosophy and there are
amazing ways that it could be
implemented the book was incredibly
informative for me particularly since
this is part two and I wasn't in part
one in terms of figuring out her
backstory and sort of where she came
from and why she believed what she
believed and what her relationships were
who would Iran vote for in this election
the current president
Kenney of course not a love story Iran
said she she wanted it first and
foremost to be a love story
yeah it is a love story it's a love
story of you know it's a love story of
freedom first and foremost
right and then it's a love story of you
know monkey sex well said with a love
story the most important thing to you is
she once said it was well certainly her
connection to him is really driving
force in the book and they're both
they're equal passion for what they do
and how much they believe in what they
do and that their workers and creators
and innovators is such a deep part of
their connection and as sort of them
against the world libertarian now I am
NOT maybe in part three